[Musique]
bonjour je suis Jean-Baptiste Laverne
rozzani et je vous souhaite la bienvenue
au restaurant La Table du 11 on a
également le Bistrot du 11 et la cave du
11 et ce matin on va réaliser un plat
tout autour de l'huître Gilardeau
gribiche et une sauce balsamique blanc
[Musique]
on va débuter sur l'huître givardot donc
là on est sur la numéro une c'est ce qui
se fait de plus gros chez eux c'est le
plus gros calibre pas évidente avec ce
producteur là parce que sur les gros
calibre on n'a pas le côté un petit peu
laiteux qui peut être gênant certaines
fois ensuite on va mettre un vinaigre de
sapin donc bio qui vient des Vosges on
va venir tourner autour de notre dessous
[Musique]
ensuite on va continuer avec la sauce
gribiche
[Musique]
ensuite sauce balsamique blanc
ensuite huile de persil on va venir
remplir la partie blanche de l'assiette
qui nous reste en visuel
[Musique]
ensuite on va mettre graines de moutarde
réhydrater flèche
[Musique]
pour mettre la dernière touche végétale
on va utiliser le shiso donc on va
mettre une demi-feuille de chez au frais
et on va terminer avec une feuille de
ciseaux qu'on vient travailler en temps
pour a pour avoir un côté un peu
croustillant sur le plat
et voici l'huître Gilardeau avec sauce
gribiche et sauce balsamique blanc donc
là l'idée pour avoir la sauce gribiche
qui est naturellement une sauce un petit
peu gourmande qui se mange avec la tête
de veau avec des morceaux là on vient
faire une sauce très lisse donc l'idée
c'est que vous mettiez tous vos
ingrédients de la sauce gribiche dans un
mixeur vous mixez tout ensemble et
ensuite vous la passez au chinois et
vous aurez une sauce très lisse en tout
cas je vous souhaite bon appétit
[Musique]